A movie has just come out called
"The Imitation Game"
starring Benedict Cumberbatch as Alan
Turing and
Keira Knightley as one of the the team that
worked with Turing -  her name was Joan Clarke.
[ALAN TURING: ... five minutes and 34 seconds ...]
[JOAN CLARKE: ... you said to do it in under six ...]
And I'm sure many of you know
Alan Turing worked at the Government Code
and Cypher Centre at Bletchley Park
throughout the war, right from when it
broke out in 1939
right through until the end the war
in 1945.
Alan Turing was at Princeton doing
research with another
very famous mathematical logician called
Alonzo Church.
He returned from Princeton in 1938 but
even in that year,
from '38 to '39, it's very clear
that he was contacted by GC & CS
even though he wasn't employed by them.
And became a sort of
consultant; became acquainted with all
the difficulties that were going to
hit the Allies when war broke out
- as seemed
inevitable - in deciphering German
ciphers that had been done on this Enigma
machine. Now an awful lot of the material
that I'm going to be using today, really,
uses as a reference book
this one by Andrew Hodges. It's called
"Alan Turing - the enigma"
This has been reprinted, republished - I
think in a slightly newer edition -
because "The Imitation Game" is based
on this account of Turing's life.
Now, Enigma goes back a long way.
Prior to its use by the German armed
forces it was just a simple commercial
cipher machine and it was a pretty
reasonable system
but I suppose you could say the number of
possibilities - the
degree to which it scrambled up the
message, was considerable
but not ultra, ultra safe,
I think it was a machine that - as they
say in the cryptological trade -
was designed to discourage casual snooping
rather than to withstand serious
attention from experts in the field.
And what I want to do is to go through
with you, in this video,
the components of the system and then in
the later one
summarise and say: "That's the problem
they were up against -
how do you make a machine that could
help you decipher
that code if you didn't know the settings
of the machines that created it
in the first place?" I'm going to cross-refer
you to some footage on our sister channel,
Numberphile. James Grime has done a couple
of videos,
on Numberphile, which actually use
a real-live Enigma machine that
belongs to Simon Singh.
Lucky James gets to use the real thing
and I would strongly recommend,
if you're puzzled by all of this, go and
watch those two videos.
One of them is just a generalized introduction
to the Enigma, the other one
explains precisely why
the Enigma machine's big flaw was that it
could never encipher
a letter as itself. Believe it or
not that is a big, big security flaw,
and does provide a way in, for people who
want to crack that particular code.
The Enigma itself looks, at first sight, a bit
like an ordinary typewriter. It's got a typewriter
board layout, there's typewriter keys,
but you then notice that if you switch it on - and
it is battery powered -
in the area just above the keys, instead of having
26 further keys, you have 26
places where a lamp can light up a letter.
So you might press a T and it will light
up as a G.
What else is there, inside this machine. How
does the key-press
get through to illuminating a lamp? Well
in the most amazing and convoluted way.
There's a set of rotors here. These
rotors have 26 alphabetic letters
engraved around the circumference.
Sometimes you don't get letters you
get numbers 0, 1, ... through to 26, but it
comes down to the same thing in the end.
When the lid is closed on top of them
the letter - as it were - pointing
upwards on the rotor
anywhere between A to Z, shows up in
three identical
looking windows. Perhaps the easiest way
to think of it - even
for those of you viewing who are relatively
young - can you remember back to your family's first
ever car?
Where it had an old-fashioned
odometer, you know, a mileage indicator
on the dashboard
which wasn't all done in electronics, it
was actually driven off the engine
and you actually had little wheels
moving in front of you?
On the right-hand side would be the tenths
of a mile, or tenths of a
kilometre, and every time that had got
up to a 9 it would nudge
the dial to the left of it, to move on one
place, and so on.
The principle is exactly the same on the Enigma.
The right-hand rotor moves the fastest
and at a certain stage will nudge the
next one
into moving on a notch. The left hand
rotor is the slowest moving of all
and once the lid is closed on the Enigma, all
you see is the
letter on the rotor that's uppermost
showing through the windows
at the top. Now - complication upon complication,
Within each rotor there is, if you like,
on the two sides, an input stud and
an output stud,
and they are cross-wired. If you could
break open
as is shown here, the rotor mechanism,
you would see a whole bunch of 26 wires, in there,
which are cross-wiring an input stud
to an output stud. So you might get A, cross wired
to J, B cross-wired to Q,
C cross-wired to W - something like that.
When Enigma first came out there
were three sorts of rotor wheel
numbered I, II, and III, in Roman
numerals, typically,
in the German instruction manuals.
A rotor of type
II would not be cross-wired in the same way
as a rotor of type I. And similarly
a rotor of type III would be a completely
different cross-wiring.
I think many of you will know the number of ways
you can arrange three things on a
spindle like that
is 3 factorial, which is 6.  Six possible
orderings of the rotors on the spindle.
So you can begin to see the multiplication
of the number of combinations
about how this thing could be set
up in the first place.
You've got different orderings on the spindle;
you've got different cross-wirings on the
different sorts of rotors.
So for the very basic machine, then, that
was just about it. You fed the
signals through the right-most rotor
through the middle rotor with a different
cross-wiring and mapping, through the
left-hand rotor
and then there was what the Germans called
a 'reverser',
sometimes in English called the 'reflector'.
What it would do
was to return the signal back via a different
stud on the left-hand rotor so it would take a
different
journey back through the machine to the
way it came in.
Now here is the secret of why
it never mapped a letter to itself. It
couldn't because,
to make that effect happen, you'd have had
in the reflector drum here,
to say "Ah! it's coming out of the A slot;
I'm going to return it back
through the A slot". It wasn't electrically
set up to
enable you to do that. You effectively had
to decide
to cross-wire in that reflector
to something different. And I think, here,
if you look carefully
A is actually cross-wired to something like W.
Now, in the early 3-rotor Enigma, that
reflector had fixed cross-wirings
which were the same in all Enigma machines.
So, your current goes back through a different route
and then, finally, lights up a lamp
on the lamp array
just ahead on the keyboard. over here  So that's
the way it was up until about the mid-thirties.
But then, as the German armed forces were
taking more and more interest
in these things, and saying: "Oh, if we could beef
them up these could be made into
military grade security devices",
they did two things. First thing, they said
we're not just going to have three rotors in
six combinations, we're  going to do the
following: were going to invent two more rotors
called IV and V, amazingly :-)
Here's what you now do:
We will choose any three out of those five rotors
- well the ways of picking three from five is
five times four over one times two
Five factorial over three factorial [times two factorial]
The answer's 10.
But for each of those 10 ways, you can still
jumble them up in six ways on the spindle.
Ten times six is sixty, so classic
Army-Airforce Enigma
used this pretty well throughout the war.
You chose three from five
and the three you chose could be put on
the spindle
in a certain way. Now comes the real killer.
If that wasn't bad enough, the armed forces decided
that on the input to the machine and on the output
they would have another cross-wiring
board, called the Plugboard.
Now this one's simple to understand. It's
basically got sockets
numbered from A to Z and you're given
chunks of wire.
If the instructions say crosslink A
to J, that's what you did. Crosslink B
to R, you did that as well. In usual
operating practice
10 out of 13 of those plugs
would be cross-wired and wired up. You could
wire up in the pairs but you didn't
absolutely have to wire up everything. If
you left something
unwired - or 'unsteckered' as they would say in German -
then that's fine. I mean a letter Q might have
no plug in it - going absolutely nowhere.
Fine. So Q maps to Q - it's not altered
to anything else at all.
But, like I said, typically 10 out of 13
would be wired up.
So this is getting to be a pretty
complex machine now
and you would think: "By golly! surely this
is enough security for anybody?"
Well, what's good enough
for the Army and the Air Force in almost
any armed forces in the world
is never good enough for the Navy! I think
it's that case in the UK - it's certainly that
way in the US,
and it certainly was that way in Germany.
Admiral
Karl Doenitz who was the head
of the German Navy, was a very smart guy. Some
people theorize - and maybe they're right -
that he strongly suspected
as the war went on, that maybe Army and
Airforce Enigma was being
decrypted successfully, sometimes, by the
Allies, and he was determined
to make the German Navy version of Enigma
far harder.
So, first thing he did was to say: "All right,
we'll stick with three rotors for the moment
but it isn't choose 3 from 5, it's choose
3 from 8", And and by the time you've worked it
out, how many ways to pick 3 from 8,
and then multiply by 6 for the number
of ways you can arrange the three you've
chosen on the spindle,
the answer is 336.
And that's daunting! One of the things, I think,
does need a bit of careful explanation -
it's not very well done
in the various books about Bletchley Park
and Enigma, and how it worked -
is to explain what these so-called 'ring
settings' were.
Now the straightforward, internal,
cross-wiring is simple:
you just look at the top row and for every
letter you follow
vertically downwards and you say: "Okay, in
a Type I rotor
A on one side gets mapped to
E on the opposite side. B gets mapped to K;
C gets mapped to M - all the way through to
Z gets mapped to J ". But to complicate
matters just a little bit further
every one of these rotor rings had a
little blob of paint associated with
it showing
which was the proper setting. with A at
the top and A against the dot of
paint, but it had the ability to
be able to turn the thing in such way
that instead of A being against the canonical blob
something else was So, so you could
set a little notch that held it in position,
but in a place that actually was not
the standard position.
If you put your button - your ring-setting
button - against the letter B
it had the effect of making A map across
to what
B would normally have turned into. B would
normally have turned into K.
B goes to M; C goes to F; D goes to L and so on.
It's just an offsetting mechanism.
It's just moving, as it were, the bunch of
wires inside
the rotor. So, that is what a 'ring setting' is.
It's basically an initial offset, that
changes the mapping ever so subtly -
makes things even more complicated. The  final
bit of complication now, just so that we're
completely mind-blown and
think: "How on earth could this ever be decrypted
by anybody?"
You might think that just as a car's odometer
would go all the way up to 9, on the
right-hand side and the moment it
turns over at 9 it would nudge the
next one on the left, some bright spark
had the idea that it might give more security
if you made different wheel types have
different turnover points.
And Doenitz's extra rotors VI, VII and VIII -
even worse - they turn over twice!
Once at Z, and once at M - in the middle of
the alphabet.
Actually it's not a good idea if you
think about it.
And I'll tell you why. Imagine you know -
because you've done a lot of work on this - you're pretty
sure that at the moment
the machine has got a Type I rotor at the right.
And you're also pretty sure from the
cryptanalytical working
done, that it's currently on the letter N.
You then type in three more of the
received ciphertext letters.  And you
suddenly see -
you suddenly find things going completely weird.
This isn't just the same wheel
turning, something's happening,
It shouldn't have come out looking like this -
this sequence! Argh!
it's turned over the middle rotor, so if I
think it was on N and
it's turned over the middle rotor on a Q,
then it follows that that right-hand
rotor must be of Type I
and I wanted to know that all along. So
these turnover points, because they weren't
all at Z to A, which would have
made it all look uniform,
you know, whenever anything turns over
that's the way it does it,
had this little signature that if you're very
careful in your cryptanalysis gives the game away.
How is this all gathered together? If
you were very lucky, in the very early days
of the war,
you didn't even have to try and cryptanalyse
this incoming ciphertext traffic -
either by hand or by machine. If you
could do what Bletchley Park called
'a pinch', If you could actually get a secret agent
or an army officer
to just accidentally be able to get hold
of the code tables,
issued to the German armed forces, you
didn't have to do any cryptanalysis at all
either by hand or by using this very
expensive machinery that we'll be talking
about next time,
this electro-mecanical Bombe. You didn't have
to use those
it's all here. But as James makes very clear
in his videos
If you did get that bit of luck it never
lasted long;
you maybe got a month's worth and then a
it ran out, or
someone back at headquarters said: "I'm not happy,
one of our code books seems to have been
stolen and disappeared.
I'll tell you what, even though there's six
months to go on it, we're throwning it away and
issuing another one -
just to be on the safe side".
We've assumed and it's quite right
that the good thing about Enigma
from the cryptanalysis point of view
it started off life as a commercially available
totally open machine so
you might think: "Well the wiring inside those
rotors then -
three of the rotors at least, I, II and III -
would be known?"
Yes, but of course the moment the Luftwaffe and
the Army started
introducing two more rotors you've then got
the problem
of "Can we steal these things or do we
have to work out from first principles,
and with rather a lot of advanced Group
Theory and mathematics, and a lot of known
ciphertext and plaintext, and all sorts -
can we work out what the wiring is
in those rotors without actually having
them?" And the answer is,
eventually, "Yes", but it's very very nice
if somebody helps you on this front.
What did you need
to know in order to decrypt a cipher stream
done within Enigma, that your listening
stations had picked up ?.
It was transmitted in Morse as single letters
sent to Bletchley Park - what do you need to
know to make any sense of this?
Number 1:  which rotor wheels are in use?
Number 2: what is the ordering,
left to right, of those rotor wheels ?
Number 3:
for each of those rotor wheels where has
that stud
been located that does the ring
setting - against which letter ?
The fourth thing, which
we haven't mentioned very much, but which
in the next video we'll say a lot about
the operator himself - usually himself
not herself -
had to also do what was called a
'message setting'.
for this particular message. Every
separate message had to have a different
message setting.
It wouldn't have been safe just to keep
using the ring settings alone
without any alteration to those. So
that had to be worked out as well.
And finally - last but not least - the plug
board cross-connections had to be worked out.
Now that's a lot of stuff. In the very
early days of simple Enigma,
where therw were only three rotors, not
chosen from anything else,
just three, we'll find out next time that
the Polish Cipher Bureau had a lot of success
by hand, and with a very simple machine, in
getting things decrypted. But the
moment you start adding more rotors,
plugboard and all the complications you
rapidly find
the you just don't have enough time in
the day to decrypt all that you'd like to do.
The sheer weight of cipher traffic takes over.
You have to mechanise.